bang-bang what's up guys while Walsh is
trying to get rich the rest of us is
trying to get our lunch money right it's
lunch money time I'm here with the
beautiful and intelligent Polina
Mironova
she is armed and dangerous today she's
got the guns out look at her ready to go
are you yeah okay give us a little fly
salutely not alright what's going on
Jamie Dimon Jamie Dimon says coronavirus
crisis is a wake-up call for a more
inclusive economy what does that mean I
know you wrote about it in this
morning's off-pump newsletter newsletter
thing because I read it oh you read oh
nice you read the Internet there we go
we got a genius he wrote like a little
memo sent it out and basically said look
Crone virus is bad we're doing
everything we can to help our employees
our community our customers and at the
end he put three paragraphs about trying
to rebuild the economy in a more
inclusive and equitable way look it's
great intention I have no doubt that he
actually needs it he hopes that we could
do that it's easy to do that say that
when you've got hundreds of millions of
dollars if not billions of dollars and
you run a multinational global behemoth
in the finance industry but I do believe
that these guys generally do want to see
wealth and if all they go away and stuff
like that the question is how do you do
it if you are him what would you do with
the billions of dollars that I know how
would you create a more equitable
Society oh well so I think what Goldman
is doing goldman sachs they have the
10,000 women initiative i think and they
basically give money to entrepreneurs
across the world I think I would do
something like that if I had the money I
would create a program to encourage
entrepreneurship because that's the best
way to help people become wealthy so I
actually agree with you that yes
encouraging people to become
entrepreneurs and build things in own
equity is the best way to get people out
poverty and build wealth but I do not
believe that just giving them the money
to do it is necessarily the best way I
think one you have to educate them on
money economics personal finance all
that kind of it's like education access
to capital and then wealth all right I'm
on board for that
the other thing that you could do is you
could get rid of inflation by moving to
a deflationary asset as gold or sort of
currency and then you wouldn't have all
of the issues I wrote about it today I
don't feel like going over it again but
basically that is the way that you can
drive equitable societies alright what's
going on with the media layoffs are you
chill are you freezing us out you have
turned it off I like it cold sorry you
know why right I'm too hot to handle so
I gotta keep it cold up in this place
little bear mobile hibernation mode it's
not looking good in the legacy media
world oh there have been more than 20
point five million jobs that have been
lost not just the media across the board
but media has been hit hard because it's
largely you know it's an advertising
based business
a lot of them are so Conde Nast laid off
a hundred people and furloughed another
hundred BuzzFeed furlough 20 people
courts 80 layoffs vise 155 layoffs The
Economist's 90 layoffs I think this will
only continue you know who's not
suffering in the media world the things
that people want to read and watch
because most of these media companies
actually we're not creating things of
value they were simply creating things
that were nice-to-haves not need to have
if you look there's media companies
actually that are doing better than
they've ever done before most of the
mainstream media the television the
ratings all this stuff they're doing
better than they've ever done before
that's because they do whether you agree
with the accuracy of what they say they
provide something that is a need to have
right or on the news and things like
that not a want to have and it's not as
commoditized
as say so the other so I agree that I
think the commoditized type news is
probably going to suffer the most I
think the people who provide value and
that have gained trust
the readers will continue to grow which
is why sub stack is such a cool place
because it allows for individual writers
to make a living through subscription
versus subscription model so the
subscribers are paying the writer the
right are directly not going through the
advertising model well it's exactly what
people want anyways guys want to read
that person I want to read all of your
people I want to read that one person so
why not just give them the money rather
than give you to everybody else right in
this way you you know that your money is
going directly to the person that you
trust we'll talk about it later when we
talk about barstool but the other thing
that the media companies that are doing
well understand is that it's
entertainment it's not only information
accuracy news well you need the
information accuracy in news they don't
yes you do Maina you see do if this will
show was fake news people wouldn't
launch yes they would no they wouldn't
it's called wrestling you ever seen WWE
it's literally a fake sport it's
scripted it's hard it's physically
taxing on people who do it but it's
scripted ok it's a multi-billion dollar
company just saying all right eSports
jobs eSports jobs what's going on be
sports the opposite side of layoffs
there the job market in eSports is
booming a six-figure salary job market
is booming in eSports how does it feel
to be so unathletic that you're not even
considering me Sport athlete you not
even you're not even good at video games
yeah you guys there was a crime scene
last night I smoked her in chess and
backgammon and then literally she just
started complaining it was it it was a
massacre
I felt bad I thought that I might have
to call the police and put up the crime
tape cuz it literally was disgraceful I
beat her so bad in chess I didn't move
and half the pieces on the board I
didn't even touch my own pieces is
systemic did you lose a chess this is
wrestling did you lose that chess Inc
Russell did you lose the chest yes Jews
at backgammon I wanted the game of skill
and the game of luck is doing really
well in this job market so if you were
playing video games it's great if you
were a kid and you
who said hey I don't think that I can be
athletic enough to go play professional
sports which 99.9% of kids cannot do
right that's why the professional sports
do you think it's a viable path now for
kids to go and try to become
professional eSports players yes I do
and I think I interviewed this VC who
invests in eSports companies and he said
that in the future it's not gonna be
like I want to be like Tom Brady it's
gonna be like I want to be like ninja
who I've been told as a big eSports
gamer
oh yeah the hair but I also I don't even
think that it's only for kids who are
not athletic I think it's also for kids
who maybe have a physical disability and
this opens up a whole new world for them
well it's for every kid I mean obviously
those kids obviously have issues with
playing traditional sports so this is a
great outlet but every kid whether
you're physically disabled not your
athletic you're not whatever you can
play eSports I was disgusting at Madden
back in the day it's football game don't
worry but my big question is you know
that like helicopter parents where like
the game of the sporting a bit and
they're standing there next to John and
they're like Johnny hit the homerun you
know they're screamin yawn and then
sometimes you see the viral videos were
like the dad's at the ballpark like
getting a fight with each other at the
Little League baseball game is that what
goes on in the East Force but there's
not together so like some kids there
he's punching all the buttons and the
dads like Johnny go faster you think so
yeah yeah I don't know
there's millions of dollars online done
pretty interesting hard hype today yeah
I'm ready for the people I'm ready drink
coffee like six hours ago you know why
cuz I woke up early and I was ready to
go workout and plena stayed and slept
and didn't let me go until she woke up
good change this show to lunch money
confessions is that not accurate we went
running at 7:45 I don't know where you
were from the 45 minutes okay all right
tick tock CEO what's going on she's
pinching me again assault assault
tick tock see you don't just show up
with your gun is out weaponizing okay
so Kevin Maher who is the head of the
Walt Disney Company's direct-to-consumer
international business is leaving to
become CEO of tic TOCs as
as CEO of the parent company of tik-tok
which is bike dance good move bad move I
think it's an interesting move because I
think that this means that well first of
all I think Kevin Mayer I read somewhere
that basically he left because he was
passed over for CEO at Walt Disney this
might be fake news but look it up
yourselves I'm pretty sure that's true
but anyway so I think it's interesting
for tick-tock though because they're
getting the super talented guy who is a
Disney knows all the secrets to building
a media business do you think tick tock
will pivot more in the direction of less
of a social network more as a media
company hot take in coming sit down put
your seat belts on hot take this is what
happens when you pass over Talent
there's only one person who could become
the new CEO obviously Bob Seger Roxy Bob
Iger did not he stepped into executive
chairman if you remember then he kind of
hostile took back over a leadership
Kevin Maher got passed over so he
bounces he becomes the tic-tock CEO
there's one of two worlds that happens
here this is either an absolute genius
move by him and tick tock and it works
wonderfully and they continue this
meteoric rise or my hot take there's a
higher probability than not that this is
a horrible higher because Maher is very
talented but he's very talented his
skill set and experience is very very
different than the user-generated
content of a social platform but he's
the one who also led the Disney Plus
launch and completely different but I
also read that tick tock will be moving
away from user-generated content it'll
still have that but it's going to launch
like reality yeah it's basically it's
probably gonna be it's gonna try to be
the kwibi it's gonna try to be the
Disney Plus whatever so I again if
that's really where they're going this
is a fantastic hire didn't you say on
this show that tick tock has a better
chance of launching short film video
content then kwibi does of doing it I
mean you're acting like I'm not Radames
like it wasn't that hard to see that
it's they have short form video that's
user-generated now all of a sudden they
just go and say hey Kevin Hart or the
rock or some other celebrity why don't
you
do the videos will script them and then
we'll put him on the same platform like
that's not rocket science I'm not going
to Mars I was trying to go to sleep last
night like a good human so I could be
prepared for the 7:00 a.m. run and he
was like tick tock we got to see some
tick tock I was charging my watch I
couldn't go to sit down my watch and
then I actually fell asleep without my
watch
alright Barstow let's talk about some
bars I'm ready to talk about this oh she
opened the article there who's that can
we just play the music and dance while
we talk all right go ahead you were too
high for me today I can't handle you I
might be like this every day leave a
comment if you want me to be like this
every day good bar stool I don't know
anything about bar stool I've gotta say
Dave Portnoy used to annoy the crap out
of me he's grown on me a little bit
you're such a liar
you don't know anything about bar stool
from you I don't listen to it I don't
read it yeah but you know everything
about I don't look at hot girls what
that was bait for all of you men out
there that was bait I didn't take it I
sidestepped it did you see that that's
an expert move I've been living with her
for a long time not taking the bait so
long story short is barstool sports for
those that don't know is a media company
they basically owned the Internet they
are all over social media they've got
podcast they've got newsletter or
they've got websites they do all kinds
of stuff it is a very fanatical young
very very engaged audience excuse me
excuse mail of course they have been at
this for a very long time
Dave poor lies the founder he hired two
girls to come to barstool sports and
start a podcast call her daddy that
podcast became the number one female
podcast in the world the reason is it's
two girls who are young probably there I
think they're like mid-20s and they talk
about sex and of course that gets
downloads you talk about taboo stuff on
the Internet everyone wants to pay
attention so it's the number one podcast
for females in the world they make
barceló hundred thousand dollars per
episode on average and these two girls
got paid half a million dollars give or
take each last year there's a contract
dispute they want
money they feel like they're not being
compensated they want the IEP they want
all this nonsense the best part about
the whole thing is that one of the girls
went and got a boyfriend boyfriend's
ruined everything every guy and girl
knows that yeah BAM fiancee once you get
the fiancee then it's like you're cool
when you're on the boyfriend side you
ruin [ __ ] what you ruin in my life
you're still here so when when when got
a boyfriend that boy if it works HBO
Sports is an executive forget
competitive they did a hit piece on
barstool sports recently and so this guy
then basically went and he shot this
podcast even though they were so under
contract got another deal is this huge
drama the most important part of it
though is that barstool the way they
handled these kind of crisis is most
people would do one of two things they
would either everyone be quiet no one
say anything right and let all the
rumors float out there or to is they
would go to like a crisis communications
firm they would get some message drafted
and be like oh we regret that this
happened and we promise to do better and
have this big corporate message what
they did is Dave Portnoy I literally
recorded a podcast and released it on
the podcast feed for called her daddy
and he touted daddy speaks and he
literally for 30 minutes sits there and
just explains with full transparency
this is what happened this is what we
paid them here's how the contract
negotiation went here's why I thought it
was a good deal I can't believe they're
not taking it whatever and what ends up
happening is now barstool walks away
from this looking amazing it was a great
piece oh yes I will say someone who
spent the majority of my professional
career in media this is an expert move I
mean this thing will be studied for
years it's incredible how he got ahead
of the narrative because likely this
girl's boyfriend was gonna sue bar stall
for all sorts of stuff no I don't think
that he was gonna sue her I think there
was gonna be people who sued for sure
there would be lawsuits against a bar
store and so by getting ahead of the
story you saw the narrative kind of
evolved on social media I went on
Twitter in low
at some of the fans on call her daddy
and they were like daddy gang that's
what they're called the daddy gang but
they were like they you can tell they
were very devoted to these two women who
hosted the podcast but after listening
to Portnoy explained like oh and by the
way they each got paid half a million
million sorry half a million dollars
each but while on the podcast they were
pretending they don't make any money and
they were a poor yeah their host Rick
was were young girls in New York City we
don't get paid a lot of money that we go
out and party and like woe is us let's
talk about sex as a wise philosopher
once said the coronavirus is exposing
the Sham gonna start calling me
Nostradamus right now you know what else
this is they got money they got paid get
money get paid those girls got paid they
got half a million dollars each well but
now so the drama is one girl wants to
take the deal with barstool and continue
getting paid half a million dollars
guaranteed guaranteed half a million
dollars the new contract plus upside but
my favorite part of the entire thing is
Dave Portnoy he never seen it crisis he
don't like he's never seen that
controversy that he would avoid so
instead he comes out and he immediately
starts to call the boyfriend soup man
he's just like in soup man did this and
soup man did that nobody and within he
minutes within minutes of this going
live
they had a merchandise store open on
their website and you could buy
sweatshirts and t-shirts and all kinds
of gear that says cancel suit man and I
guarantee they're selling tens of
thousands of dollars if not hundreds of
thousands of dollars with that it really
sucks for you proven if half of what
they're saying he did is true I don't
feel bad for that guy at all he's
getting mean to death on the internet by
the barstool fans because it's a scumbag
move if if what they say if what they
say
he did if he actually said I'm going to
try to hurt barstool by taking one of
their media properties I'm gonna go sell
it to somebody else even while they're
under contract and then try to help my
girl
and her friend sue or get out of that
contract just come back MOOC just honor
your contract so okay so what would you
do if I was a nine girls position and
you were getting like canceled t-shirt
man Oh immediate immediately first of
all you know me and Dave are probably
somewhat someone that we like
controversy so the first thing I would
do was I would immediately release a
diss track I'd go right at him and then
to is I would release dear of course
like you're laughing already you're like
immediately that's the best thing that
guy can do because he's got the thing
about he suit man if he plays into it go
create like the WWE type like showdown
and I'm in some weird way he actually
could create a situation where bar stool
will then hire him and be the Nemesis in
the end of program that would be ideal
in an ideal are saying hey Peter Nelson
if you need ideas call me I'll be your
age and I'll be your console the air
isn't that what it's going yeah I'll be
your brain for you based on what I've
seen though on the Internet
I don't think Peter or suit man is uh I
think he's too serious juice hey dish
track is the best way baby
all right dinosaur selfie tennis or
selfies what's going on here
so okay well hold on let me take a
picture with this dinosaur we might not
have an episode so dinosaur selfies oh
my god what did you have this morning
cancelled t-shirt man slow deep pretty
good what's going on the dinosaurs I
just I can't deal with you today
dinosaurs this man broke into the cost
rally is oldest Museum he was caught on
the security cameras for forty minutes
he was in this museum walking around and
taking selfies with the dinosaurs
this guy's a hero he didn't break in he
was trying to set the dinosaurs free he
wasn't there taking pictures he was
documenting the fact that they have
dinosaurs in captivity and he was China
releasing it he's wearing a button-down
shirt and some khaki pants and says he's
an international student what do you
want to bet he's international from the
United States who cares it's because
Americans want freedom he's trying to
break the dinosaur bones ow
American tourists ruin everything you
don't even know they're American this is
fake news fake news fake news all right
you let us you let us know t-shirt man
okay shirt man we're not gonna start
that that's not gonna be at the day
we're gonna cancel those guns come on
give us one [ __ ] you've been working out
give us a lecture
tune in tomorrow for the diss track all
right guys that's it today for lunch
money well while she's trying to get
rich the rest of us are trying to get
our lunch money right like the video so
that more people can see it subscribe to
the channel I know some of you guys are
watching this video you're not
subscribed go subscribe me figure out
who you are please don't like this video
because I don't know people watching
this nonsense today alright we're gonna
have a conversation after this and leave
a comment we'll do our best to respond
we will talk to you guys tomorrow